e la luce fu nella genesi appena dopo il
cielo e la terra dio crea la luce e le
tenebre e poco dopo le stelle e due luci
una più potente per il giorno il sole è
una meno intensa anzi direi io di merate
per la notte la luna mi ha sempre
colpito questa importanza che viene data
alla luce è considerato elemento vitale
primordiale ma mi spaventa un po questa
imposizione divina della luce stessa
questa imposizione monodirezionale è
rimasta inalterata nei millenni anche
l'illuminazione degli spazi dove sono
predefiniti valori e tipologia di
illuminazione oggi è in atto una nuova
rivoluzione che sconvolge questa
prospettiva e mette in dialogo continuo
la luce è l'uomo
ma cos'è la luce per l'uomo
la luce è quello che fa brillare questo
paesaggio in montagna luce anche
luminanza luce che viene riflessa in
maniera diversa dalle superfici chi
preferisce questa immagine a quella
precedente 40 60
abbiamo appena dimostrato che non esiste
una luce oggettivamente perfetta ma una
luce soggettivamente migliore luce e
anche buio luce contrasto la percezione
è un qualcosa che il nostro cervello
genera partendo da una determinante e
genetica dalle interazioni con
l'ambiente dalle proprie esperienze
conoscenze e dalla luce stessa che ci fa
vivere le cose in maniera differente la
prossima immagine luminosa potrà
suscitare in alcuni di voi una forte
emozione a me forse e cita ancora di più
questa la luce e in particolar modo
l'illuminazione stradale è una parte
fondamentale della mia vita
se infatti chi cammina con la testa fra
le nuvole
c'è chi cammina ammirando il paesaggio
le vetrine io cammino guardando i
lampioni grazie a una passione che ho
sin da bambino l'astronomia
ho avuto delle idee ottiche che ho
brevettato che consentono grazie a una
riflessione multipla della luce di
raggiungere nei illuminazione stradale
un grande risparmio energetico e
soprattutto un elevato confort visivo e
così a 28 anni ho deciso di trasformare
queste idee in un'azienda ma il comfort
visivo
l'abbiamo visto prima ha un'elevata
componente soggettiva dinamica mutevole
proprio per questo la prossima sfida che
vorrei intraprendere è quella di far
parte di questa nuova rivoluzione
copernicana che mette l'uomo al centro
dell'universo della luce e mette in
dialogo continuo luce e duomo per lo
meno nell illuminazione stradale che
rappresenta la spina dorsale perché
capillarmente diffusa delle smart city
del futuro
già da tempo si parla di illuminazione
adattiva cioè della possibilità di
dotare i lampioni stradali di sensori di
presenza in modo da illuminare le strade
di notte
solo quando passano le macchine ma un
sensore di presenza
ce l'abbiamo già tutti in tasca ed è
questo collegando i nostri smartphone ai
corpi illuminanti
facciamo in modo che essi possano
predire in maniera continuativa i valori
precisi di traffico nelle strade e nei
marciapiedi andando a predisporre ora
per ora il livello corretto di
illuminazione dinamico sulla strada e
sul marciapiede non semplicemente
semplicemente diminuendo i livelli di
illuminazione di notte del 30 per cento
come si fa adesso
quantità e qualità della luce diversa
più calda dopo il tramonto e più fredda
nelle ore centrali della notte
tutti noi abbiamo sperimentato quanto a
volte sia fastidioso guidare di notte
quando piove cambiando l'ottica dei
corpi illuminanti si può essere in grado
di eliminare questo questo aspetto e
quindi di fare l'illuminazione corretta
per ogni tipo di condizione atmosferica
pioggia neve nebbia una luce che ti
guida anche scommetto che già molti di
voi si stanno registrando all'evento del
decs a padova il 13 maggio e scommetto
anche che qualcuno starà pensando ma in
centro a padova alla macchina dove la
parcheggio i corpi illuminanti che
illuminò i parcheggi possono ad esempio
rilevando la luminanza riflessa dalle
superfici capire quali sono i parcheggi
disponibili e dirci e quale è il
parcheggio più vicino darci la
possibilità di prenotarlo e indicarci
non solo la strada più veloce con minor
traffico come fa già google maps
sfruttando i servizi di localizzazione
abilitati sul cellulare ma anche
collegandoci alle nostre agende e con
qualche algoritmo di intelligenza
artificiale suggerendoci la strada più
adatta al nostro mood se abbiamo voglia
di relax sarà un sarà una strada magari
panoramica con luce più calda se siamo
stanchi una strada più veloce con luce
più fredda ma come faremo a collegare
tutti i nostri cellulari ai lampioni
qual è il modo per rendere massivo
questo collegamento
la soluzione è semplice e anche
automatica spostare i ripetitori dei
cellulari dalle grandi antenne che
creano grandi campi elettromagnetici e
macro celle all'interno dei corpi
illuminanti stessi andando a creare un
network in cui ogni cellulare diventa
ogni corpo illuminante diventa il
ripetitore
segnale così segnale diventa più
direzionato quindi con la possibilità di
maggiore velocità nello scambio di dati
e anche potenzialmente meno intenso con
la possibilità di andare a diminuire i
valori in funzione dei terminali
effettivamente presenti all'interno
delle microcelle avremo così a
disposizione una miriade di dati da
analizzare per provare a dare
esattamente l'illuminazione soggettiva
per tutte le persone i dati diventeranno
quindi il nuovo modello di business
dell'illuminazione ulteriore al
risparmio energetico e alla vendita dei
servizi del resto facebook due anni fa
ha comprato whatsapp per mi pare 19
miliardi di dollari e in cambio ho avuto
all'epoca erano poco più di 600 milioni
di utenti
quindi o ha valutato i dati di ogni
utente che quello che ha veramente
comprato circa 20 30 dollari
c'è un corpo illuminante ogni dieci
persone e quindi il valore di dati
potenziali per ogni lampione stradale è
sufficiente a pagare questa nuova
infrastruttura questa tecnologia
abilitante per rendere le città e smart
city del futuro e quindi qual è il più
grande ostacolo per realizzare questo
intervento non tecnologico non economico
come abbiamo visto il più grande
ostacolo e affrontare questi progetti
individualmente
la tecnologia è solo il mezzo poi ci
vogliono le persone e la creatività
innovation and collaboration e quando
pensiamo alla condivisione di dati alla
collaborazione tra luce ed uomo non
penso possiamo pensare di affrontarlo se
non in maniera integrata sviluppando
avere alleanze tra aziende di lighting
di telecomunicazioni di elettronica di
intelligenza artificiale di servizi web
piccole aziende medie aziende e grandi
imprese start up incubatori enti di
ricerca universitari
solo così potremo dare vita ad una nuova
luce e dire e la luce è anzi è la luce
siamo grazie a tutti
[Applauso]